[Music]
the challenge for this video was making
a non-contact fight scene as interesting
as a normal fight scene
this is rendering i'm trying to
literally nothing is working today
i've made
zero progress
literally nothing's working
what are we doing yeah we're gonna see
if we can hold our breath as long as
they do in the movies wait what
what
what do you mean
what are we doing we have all these
underwater teams movies particularly tom
cruise does this all the time and they
hold their breath and i want to see if
we can hold our breath as long as they
do in the movie scenes i already know i
can't
no
i know i know your whole body
i was just making funny sounds all right
so stop it
does anybody else want to join us for
the hold your breath challenge to see if
you can hold your breath for as long as
movie stars do in the movies yes okay
all right this is your test to see if
you're a real movie star guys i'm so
all right here we go
ready as soon as he dives in
right he's gonna dive in ready
i got lightheaded
whoa
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
oh i got a cramp on my neck
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i almost burst out laughing when ren
started breathing because he took him
like two seconds
so i tried hyperventilating myself but
then i ended up just making myself
really lightheaded so i started seeing
spots all over the place
in my legs let's go again round two
hey guys i'm kevin zuzaki and i'm the
sound designer on the flinch fight video
so on this video i'm handling all the
post-production audio so that includes
cleaning up the dialogue doing the sound
effects and then doing the mix i've been
working with corridor for a few years
now and i think the first video we did
together officially was far cry 3 video
we did the division together we
collectively were actually nominated for
a golden reel award which is this
illustrious award that the sound editing
community gives to itself and we lost so
we are an award losing award nominated
but award losing sound designer kevin
senzaki right here the challenge for
this video was making a non-contact
fight scene as interesting as a normal
fight scene you know where people hit
each other like it's kind of usually the
point of fighting we don't have that
here
so
so normally in a fight scene there's
what i call like a one-two rhythm to it
which is basically like your whooshes
before the hit and then your actual hit
so when someone's coming into punch it's
you have push hit woo [ __ ] it's a one
two one do
the thing and that's usually what you
build the rhythm of the fight scene
around anticipation like the whoosh is
building excitement and then you have a
release you have a hit and you play with
that in terms of your timing your pitch
and your rhythm and that's how the fight
scene hangs together dramatically in
this situation we have all this
anticipation we have all these punches
that are coming in but there's never a
resolution
i found that i had to do fully for
almost everything and fully that's all
those little incidental sounds related
to characters moving it's usually their
footsteps it's usually their cloth
moving around you usually don't need to
do that much fully in this fight scene
where there's no actual hits i found
that by giving it fully so we could
really hear every footstep that helped
fill in the silence that's created by
them not punching each other in the face
i found rhythmically that was actually
really important so there's a lot of
placing like a little shoe scuff or a
little shoe squeak right when they
flinch you get that sort of connection
to the character you get a dramatic
response from them when you normally
have like a big you know kapow question
that people have a lot of times is
what's the difference between a sound
editor and a sound designer
and the answer is
we're gonna do them for the rest of the
day until there's one that none of us
can do
we're gonna keep going until nobody's
conscious to press play on the next one
what if i pass out though all right the
next one is one of my favorite scenes
and then after this gonna go to some
difficulty ready some tom cruise after
this
you've seen the kingsman i don't know
well no i know exactly
you're sleeping in your bed we can't
tell anything's wrong
so
[Music]
[Music]
what's the difference between a sound
editor and a sound designer the answer
is
nothing really sound designer is kind of
an invented term on a small video like
this where i am the entire post sound
team there is no difference but it's
just arbitrarily used when someone wants
to declare him or herself an artist or
if you have a bunch of people on a show
that are all doing you know editorial
sound work and then they want to single
out one person as the person with the
vision
what i found that was really interesting
with this scene is the way i actually
approached whooshes had to be completely
different so in a normal fight scene the
whoosh is kind of whatever the most
dynamic part of the movement is the
whoosh never really sinks correctly you
just find kind of what feels right and
that leads into your hit at the end of
the movement but in this video i found
it worked better to sink the whoosh up
to the end of the hit when it stops so
it's like this dramatic build so it's
still it's still in a way satisfying
that ultimate design wise these bushes
had to be treated kind of differently so
to get a lot of the whooshes like the
bit here where clint keeps punching
there's actually a 909 bass drum sound
effect mix into there that's giving it
this kind of low end power and i felt
like creatively since we don't have any
hits we really want to feel their power
their motion through the air so there's
all these little extra elements that
kind of give you the feel of like the
atmosphere pushing away from from their
from their fists as they're cutting
through it
it sounds completely insane that i'm
saying it out loud now but hopefully it
works you know
what i love about doing stylized fight
scenes like this is there's a lot of
room to do little sound analogies as in
you can do sounds that don't make any
literal sense they can suggest something
that makes a joke funny so at the end
here as you go through and clint is
doing all the punches they're rising in
pitch and it's kind of building in this
intensity but for the final moment to
give it this literal surgical knife
quality there's a little knife sound
effect in there and i thought it just
made sense even though it doesn't
dude chill yeah i had a lot of fun doing
this one this was this was a great
little challenge because you know i
normally don't get to do a fight scene
where people don't hit each other
pieces of the way you know
non-violence
so yeah i think we got it i don't know
you tell me if we did it
i just want to do the impossible all
right guys can you hold your breath
longer than tom cruise yeah guys this
one is very difficult this is impossible
did you chop this up i'll get as far as
i can
tom cruise passes out in this scene
you didn't tell them we get to pass out
too
so hopefully you only have to make it as
long as he until he passes out yeah once
he gets rescued or whatever you're good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
too
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
something interesting
you're still going dear no you exhale
you can actually
[Music]
i forgot about the exhale
[Music]
i forgot about the exhale i forgot you
can exhale it helps a lot actually more
wind i feel pretty dizzy listening to
the movie effects is really the
difficult part that heartbeat on the
last one freaked me out
so you gotta breathe out you gotta get
that bad that bad air out keep the good
air in
i was still like a minute i still would
have had to hold my breath for a minute
i appreciate air you wanna know my pro
tips are holding my breath yeah dude so
some people probably actually do free
diving in the comments and they'll give
you actual tips but general rule of
thumb is you hyperventilate for as long
as you want to hold your breath breathe
for your whole body
and then it's the buildup of co2 in your
blood that triggers
you wanting to like let it go so it's
important to take a big breath of air
hold it as long as you can
let out a little pressure if you need to
and then once you're starting to feel it
let it out slowly buy yourself some time
and then once it's all gone you have
about another 30 seconds relax focus on
slowing down your heart rate don't use
your body like actually the second time
around like if you hold your breath
until you can't anymore and you stop and
you breathe deeply and kind of get just
a little dizzy again you hold your
breath again you'll be able to go longer
that second time because your body's
already adapted to
not having as much oxygen so if you guys
have any other ideas for insane movie
challenges we should try put them in the
comments below and subscribe if you're
not to watch us try to attempt them
and just for good measure here's david
hasselhoff saving someone from a hand
grenade